the very last Boeing 747 will be
delivered to Atlas Air tomorrow for use
as a cargo plane Say It Ain't So for
more than 50 years the 747 has been
praised for broadening air travel and
bridging wide distances Chris Van Cleave
went to the plant north of Seattle that
built the final 747 and met some of the
people who've spent Generations working
on it
[Music]
we'll bring you the world's first 747
even before Boeing 747 flew its first
passengers Back in 1970 the world knew
this was something special so what do
you think still intimidating and from
day one the Anderson family has quite
literally had their hands on nearly
every single 747 built working on the
production line in Everett Washington
Andy Anderson was a supervisor on the
Prototype his son Vic is now a lead
mechanic on the last one and about 875
before it he turned him on and I'll be
turning them off means a lot to to our
family really we were there in December
as Vic took his dad to see the final
assembly of the final Queen of the Skies
just days before it rolled off the line
took its first test flight and got
bathed in about 120 gallons of paint
ahead of its final delivery tomorrow I
may miss it I already miss it back in
1969 Andy Anderson was back in this same
plant as they built the world first
jumbo jet twice the size of the largest
airliner to date across everybody's mind
whether it was going to get off the
ground or not when you saw that first
one fly what went through your mind it
gave you Goosebumps everybody wanted to
fly for a gym they still do
right
and for more than five decades its four
engines have carried millions of
Travelers six presidents and even the
space shuttle across the country and
around the world but newer more
fuel-efficient planes with two engines
are bringing about the end of the 747.
Mike Lombardi is Boeing's historian this
airplane marks the point in history
first time that any person on planet
Earth could get on an airplane and fly
it democratized air travel absolutely
you could say that it Shrunk the world
Boeing Engineers thought this
mid-century engineering Marvel would
only fly passengers for a decade before
supersonic planes like the Concord
became the norm they designed the 747 to
live on as a freighter which is how it
got that iconic hump allowing for a nose
that could open to load cargo so it's
fitting the final 747 is a freighter
that'll be delivering for years to come
after building
1574 747s
this marks the end of the line for the
queen of the skies for the Andersons
Waterberg I never thought I would
Outlast her it's still the queen it's a
bit like saying goodbye to a part of the
family
for CBS mornings I'm Chris Van Cleave in
Everett Washington
and we thank those teams that built
those plans for all those years